une première pierre symbolique le 22
janvier 1963 était signé le traité de
l'élysée donnant naissance en 1975 au
lycée franco-allemand qui connaît
aujourd'hui une rénovation complète des
travaux d'un montant de 56 millions
d'euros pris en charge par la région et
le département la région veut des lycées
campus aujourd'hui très tourné vers
l'enseignement supérieur la préparation
de la vie professionnelle et et tout ça
évidemment ça conduit à des milices en
ce sens a conduit à des études
supérieures de lettres le département
des yvelines avec la région ile de
france voulait véritablement aboutir
jusqu'au moment où le département a pris
la décision de faire parce que
la région disait oui mais ne nous
accompagner pas jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait
la volonté de valérie pécresse qui vient
de s'exprimer
soixante neuf salles d'enseignement plus
de douze mille mètres carrés un gymnase
et un plateau sportif ouvert au public
accueillant aujourd'hui près de 900
élèves le lycée pourra recevoir jusqu'à
1300 jeunes et une listes d'attentes
alors c'est peut-être lié au fait qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul établissement en france
aujourd'hui et où on essaye de venir ici
suivre un enseignement de qualité mais
portait sur une culture internationale
et sur un cursus qui permet aux élèves
d'aller très facilement ensuite faire
leurs études à l'étranger
l'anglais est aujourd'hui c'est comme
les mathématiques il faut le savoir
l'allemand est un vrai atout en plus et
ça les gens se rencontrent que ça
l'aurait ça d aide dans leur avenir
personnel professionnel culturel
les premiers pas des élèves dans leurs
nouveaux locaux devraient se faire pour
la rentrée 2021
la dernière phase des travaux est prévue
pour le 31 mars 2022